so this woman got a job rejection
she applied for a job they told her she
didn't get the job you'll see it and
then she sends something back that gets
her a second interview and it is awesome
i just woke up but i got you know
another rejection letter from a job that
i applied for and i really kind of
wanted this job
so i took a lesson from gen z and i sent
them back this
why though
anyway it worked
they sent me another email saying that
they do in fact now want to interview me
how awesome is that
i mean first of all well done well
played amazing
and secondly like are you surprised i
wasn't surprised like if i were hiring
i just hired someone actually to who
is great has a great personality made me
laugh um
very very funny guy great family man um
but sensei humor super important
you know they might have looked at that
and said wait a minute this seems like a
really fun person to have on our team
like didn't just say okay thanks boring
sent that back had a little mojo in her
step you know was like was it wasn't
afraid to send it
you know not shy probably somebody's
gonna be outspoken on the job which is
what you want someone with a sense of
humor someone who stands out someone
who's you you people want to work with
someone fun
right they don't want to work with
somebody who's like got no sense of
humor and it's always they want to work
with someone fun who would do that
and i always say this so that's my
advice
when you write your cover letters oh god
you ever read a cover letter that's just
like
i mean i i get it like you went to this
school and you like i don't know like
sold this amount of this stock or like i
mean i've fallen asleep like three times
in the course of reading that make it
interesting best cover letter i ever
read was like a story somebody actually
told a story about like how they grew up
and like how their life now
is different but it read like short
story almost amazing like hold
somebody's interest do don't be afraid
to do some something like that
you know it's not gonna work every time
maybe you're applying for for a job with
somebody's got no sense of humor you're
out of luck
but maybe that wasn't the right job for
you then because you're gonna go there
and be cracking jokes all day long and
they're going to be like
stone cold you know boring you know
that's not the right fit
so don't be afraid to put your
personality out there make it a little
fun
make a little spicy like that that was i
loved it it was amazing if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]